oh hi we're on
yeah look i haven't forgot to put the
[ __ ] up there
i forgot to put this [ __ ] up here yeah
i'm so organized
we were talking we're gonna go down get
a new laptop tomorrow
got that land cable coming we're going
to try to improve the graphics
because this this laptop's just it's
just not really up to the task
it's so creaky and ancient poor little
macintosh
yeah we'll just make that one just a
graphic design thing yeah because this
has got all my adobe [ __ ] on it yeah
i mean i still i have a subscription to
like the creative cloud stuff go shop
right that's on my other computer yeah i
can't really afford all the programs
right you know jenny just likes to do
graphic design on in the mac
probably the mac sphere the mac sphere
yeah the rest of that [ __ ] we can do
microsoft
i mean i can do it on pc but i would
rather not this microphone going it's
turned on
yeah good i hope so got to do this
review on this uh
[ __ ] weird ass movie
well we okay so there wasn't like a [ __ ]
ton
of new ones because i have like check it
out i have a list
of new ones that i've been wanting to
watch
like i really want to see come to daddy
with elijah wood
like that's kind of the main one that i
want to see and i want to see
extraordinary because that one
has been on like rotten tomatoes as
being like the number one like best
horror movie it's got like 100
yeah positive ratings it's like a cop um
but for whatever reason xbox didn't have
either one of them i think you can rent
them on youtube
but it's kind of a pain in the ass for
us to run on youtube at least on the big
tv
so we were looking for [ __ ] to rent on
the xbox and this movie came up and this
was kind of the only one that i had seen
like other people talking about so
i was like okay we'll watch that one
plus it has like
big stars and it had like imelda
staunton in it you know she was in the
harry potter movie she was in mike lee
movies like
did she win an oscar or was nominated
for oscar or something got a girl from
blade runner
yeah important to memories carla jury
she yeah she was in blade runner 2049
uh playing the woman making the memories
so this has like some
big famous people in it now this kind of
like is it i'm gonna say it's an art
flick
okay like kind of or a prestige horror
yeah
i guess is more of a kind of what i'm
saying it's a weird flick
i liked it okay this doesn't this
definitely
say some crazy [ __ ] about it probably
during the review don't take it the
wrong way i did like it
this is an art flick in a certain way
but it wasn't
as boring as a lot of flicks it did it
did kind of have like a slow burn for
that first
maybe 20 30 minutes because you
well know about an hour because you're
just trying to get grounded on what the
[ __ ] is going on
yeah you don't really know what's going
on it is weird during that time
and then all of a sudden you think you
know what's going on and then the very
end you realize you didn't know what it
was
[Laughter]
and it's very hard to review this movie
without doing spoilers
yeah and i really don't want to spoil it
so like i said that was the mantis i
gave you the testosterone
teas of the movie because i know some
guys just well was it any good that's
the first thing i wanted they want to
know
yeah it was pretty good i i will say
that this is
i did not think that you would like this
movie it has some girl power elements
but you don't find out to the very end
but it was it was the way it was told it
was kind of like justice in a certain
way or vengeance
yeah there's a tale of vengeance about
the
you know about men that do evil that's
really you know
and it's got kind of like if you're into
all that
uh paganism [ __ ] you know like wicca or
not really wicca but you know like
you know kind of like from the wicker
man and the ones where
it kind of has you think i thought i was
dealing with like
christian gods or demons now you're
dealing with [ __ ]
you know pagan ancient european pagan
type weird [ __ ]
pretty much what's going on they don't
do a lot of backstory but in a way i
think i liked that about it
yeah um say i'm sorry i wanted to
mention that sandra said that this is
our actually our
anniversary is coming up because we
posted our very first episode on august
23rd
2016. the show yeah man they're keeping
track of that [ __ ]
that's amazing i don't even got some
serious [ __ ] fans and some serious
looking that's just veterans
our patreon we're rocking on patreon we
really [ __ ] appreciate you know the
help you guys are giving us
yeah i mean especially during this
uncertain time yeah and that first month
of streaming that we did made a [ __ ]
huge impact on how much money the show
made
made and that's why we're gonna get
which is why i can't afford to get a new
laptop right
so you know we did pretty good for that
first month of stream and if you guys
could keep it up man we'd [ __ ] be
jacked because we'll just keep building
on the show
and doing more stuff jenny's going to
open up some more stuff about book
reviews
and that's what that's what i was going
to say that's why i could also afford to
like start building up a little library
for like movies like i have like all
this
these huge stacks of books back here and
uh in addition to all the ones that i
already had if it keeps
going the way it's going uh we'll be
able to come up with some [ __ ]
more badass shirt designs that we can
give out to patrons and
and fans you know i mean fans you know
have to buy on patrons we'll
we'll you know just give them out you
know what i mean [ __ ]
uh quarterly but uh we'll come up with
some cool
[ __ ] you guys will like like you know
[ __ ] like this you know stuff for the
fans
still want a canon shirt yeah i haven't
thank you very much matt
thank you very much matt matt you're
fine i have that written down you wanted
a canon logo one and like an mtv
variation like one predator like blaine
was wearing from [ __ ] people yeah
like the old school the old school yeah
even almost like a little astronaut on
it would be kind of cute yeah well i'd
like this i'd like one exactly like
like blaine had in predator okay so it's
like a predator
mtv shirt with [ __ ] a 13 o'clock
label on the back of it okay so
you know they'll understand it [ __ ]
fans will understand it
mango badger says i love the live stream
so glad you started doing them
yeah we actually i was really reluctant
because i was just kind of like god damn
it it's like we're going to run out of
stuff to talk about i'm going to be
sitting there going
uh and it's going to be like horrifying
but actually once we started
rolling and doing them they're better i
like them a lot better
it's like it like i said it's less video
editing for me to do
um i just i don't know i just feel more
relaxed doing them
which is dumb because when i do [ __ ] on
video i can edit stupid [ __ ] out but
it's like
jenny's jenny doesn't really have a
theater background as strong as mine i
guess
me doing [ __ ] i used to sing in a
choir she sang in a choir but when i was
in high school you know we did live
i did live theater and for me it was
always normal to be in front of a live
audience
and i feed off of it more you know
and in the army you're in a lot in front
of the live audience all the time your
damn unit
so it's very normal for me to talk to
lots of people at once
and uh doing the um
doing the conventions remember how easy
it was to do
to do uh conventions speaking at the
convention yeah
you know it gets i think it gets easier
the more you do it yeah
i think jenny got you got comfortable
with it with only in an hour
or so yeah i was super nervous at first
like my stomach was upset and everything
because i was like oh god i gotta talk
and bring all these people and what's
your wife i'm
gonna sound really sweet once you start
interacting with i don't want to call
them fans that's not really the way it
is you know it's kind of like we're
professional friends now you know
that's really what that sounds kind of
dirty
[Laughter]
that's kind of what youtubers are and
that's why we had an advantage over
television and [ __ ]
television and movie celebrities you
can't interact with them
you know you're going to interact with
us and that's it's a lot more
personalized experience they have a hard
time did you see johnny depp try to
become a damn
youtuber it was [ __ ] wrong like i
said why would i watch that they're not
they're not used to that they're not
used to it
[ __ ] ridiculous well the thing about
us though too is that
i mean we sit around watching like
gordon ramsay and watching the horror
movies and stuff like that at night and
like making snarky ass comments
so really you're just kind of seeing
what we normally act like
i guess most of the time yeah if you got
if any of you guys ever want to become a
youtuber my advice
is always just be yourself don't try to
be somebody
else people will see right through that
you just gotta be your [ __ ] self
and you know i gotta put a filter on
sometimes you know because i'm in front
of a [ __ ]
mixed audience of people and i know that
not everybody's gonna agree with
everything that i say so
i don't wanna offend other people but i
am going to go out there and say some
[ __ ] i mean you want this show to be fun
it's got to be fun
yeah i mean it can't be totally
sanitized or g-rated
you know what i mean well yeah i
wouldn't be able to be boring even if i
wanted to that's what you're getting
when you watched [ __ ] corporate
television
you know i mean it's [ __ ] boring so
they can't really compete with us
we're putting their asses out of
business because there's so many of us
you know it's just it's a human wave
assault
against [ __ ] the old school media
were the punk rockers of the new age
it was just like punk and the punk
rockers of the oldies yeah exactly
right when punk rock showed up it just
changed so much stuff
but well like i said it you know it
gives you like the ability to do
something you you know it puts all the
technology right in your hands and
yeah you can do [ __ ] that only like you
before
you know you needed a [ __ ] ton of money
to do it yeah somebody's saying
tom is a thespian actor that's what i
was i was
i was and that and that kind of that
kind of i
it kind of broke me of [ __ ] the
respect of actors once you've done it
and been around them and see where that
sees go
scene goes they're [ __ ] fake i do you
know what i don't think i could ever i
liked singing and stuff even though
i was always really nervous doing it in
front of people but um
i don't think i could ever be an actor
because i'm not good at pretending like
i'm not good at lying i'm not like
pretending to be something i'm not
i'm just really not good at that yeah
well it's bad for your mental health
though because if you sniff yeah that's
stay like that too long
you're just a faker and you and and
you're just always pretending to be
well yeah you like lose your identity
they don't build an idea that's why
about how crazy he is jumping up on
couches and doing scientology and [ __ ]
i can understand why scientology
attracted him at least it was
something that was happening kinda in
the real world yeah they're [ __ ]
larping
but that's not that's not the experience
he had
scientology gave him the [ __ ] a very
expensive experience you know
and [ __ ] can [ __ ] ride motorcycles
and fly helicopters and he works out and
[ __ ] you know he does his own stunts
so i i respect him more actually than
your average
[ __ ] well yeah at least he does do he
was doing his own [ __ ] yeah
sure right but yeah so uh let's get back
to chocolate
uh they're saying all kinds of stuff
yeah they they're feeling it
they're feeling this well yeah and like
i said we get to talk to you guys in
real time you know
even though we're not on here every day
we're on here like several days ago so
you can always drop in and see what
we're up to
but yeah so this was actually the first
film
uh written and directed by ramola garai
hopefully i pronounced her name right
and like i said there's some uh big
stars in this this i think it premiered
was that thunder
yeah holy [ __ ] okay something else huh
yeah that's uh you know it's summer why
am i surprised i don't know
but um yeah so it premiered at sundance
earlier this year
and then it came to uh vod
in uh july on july 24th so only like a
few days ago
so the setup of the story is there's
this guy named tomas
and he is um he's
from some unspecified country
it's somewhere in eastern europe i think
it's eastern europe from the accent i'm
not really sure
well based on the uniform of the weapon
that he had it was some kind of eastern
european country some you know somewhere
in the balkans
and he was a veteran of one of those of
some war so he was like a refugee
and he had come to the uk yeah and he
was
homeless like he was living in a
homeless shelter yeah
and it so ends up so he's at this
homeless shelter he
he keeps having like these flashbacks of
[ __ ] that happened in his
as i said unspecified home country where
he was working as this guard
like it was this guard shack guard booth
really
and it was just out in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere like there was nothing
it was just like woods and a road and
that was it
and he just kind of sat there with his
[ __ ] with his
[ __ ] gun and that was like all there
was to it so you didn't really know like
where he was coming from what war he was
fighting and what side he was on or
anything like that
yeah it was an ak-46 ak-74u
the country of blankistan that's exactly
what it is it was blanket
so then apparently at some point he
comes to the uk i believe
damn it's tearing up out there it is
yeah i believe it was uh
two years i think he said it was two
years that he'd been in england
and uh he's living in a homeless camp
the homeless camp
gets set on fire one night and
so he ends up living with he gets
approached by
imelda staunton's character who is a nun
and she says hey
you know i live in this kind of
ramshackle house
if you want to work on the house because
he said he was a builder and he's like
if you want to work on the house and fix
it up
you can work there for free so
um sounds too good to be true turns out
as most things that sound too good to be
true are it is
you know what i mean so um so he goes
there and it turns out that not only
does this nun live there but there's
also this
girl yeah that lives there a young woman
she's not a girl yeah she's pretty hot
it's the same one from blade runner
yeah she's like i said she was from
blade runner 2049
and it was it was funny because as soon
as we saw her like tom was like man i
recognized her and i was like god that
voice it's like where
i said we just saw her in something just
recently she played decker's daughter
yeah and which is like spoiler alert if
you haven't seen play runner 2049 but
yeah
yeah yeah i've seen that by now then you
check out the channel check the [ __ ] off
the channel
if you haven't seen blade runner 2 yeah
no you can unsubscribe go ahead
i just hope the new boy i hope the new
dune is good i know yeah i know you
always open that no man but yeah so
there's this young woman who also lives
there named magda
and reportedly supposedly allegedly
killing mother that lives up in the
attic
and um sometimes there's kind of
screaming and scratching coming from up
there
and yeah there's somebody up there in
that top floor it's pretty creepy
because there's stains on the ceiling
and [ __ ]
and it's a cruddy ass damn house you
know
but as it's going on you know i'm
thinking you know what is that seeping
through the [ __ ] ceiling you know is
that pissing [ __ ] and stuff and
you find out [ __ ] that this woman's
up there man she's in nasty [ __ ]
shape and um
she's crazy as hell there's something
wrong with her and he's asking her is it
what's exactly wrong with
and she he for a while he doesn't really
he doesn't really get a straight answer
it's just a [ __ ] creepy ass it's a
weird
movie you know what it reminded me of
like the director said that um
that she was kind of inspired by the
babadook although this doesn't really
remind me of the babadook
um i liked the babadook a lot but this
doesn't really remind me of that
she did say that another inspiration was
under the shadow
which was an awesome movie it might
still be on netflix that's where i saw
it but that was like quite a while ago
um which was an iranian movie
and um about like these this woman and
this kid like in this building
like a missile hit and there's like a
gin um so
that one is kind of i can see that but
you know i know this is going to be kind
of weird but you know what movie this
reminded me of the most
was i don't know if you guys have seen
there was like a turkish horror movie i
think it came out in 2014 or 2015 called
baskin
and it's very so kind of surrealist
um and it was kind of i don't know it
was really [ __ ]
it was awesome but it was like really
really [ __ ] weird and this
kind of reminded me of that like tonally
thematically a little bit um i think
that one was a little more hell razory
this one is not really like that this
one is like
i think the reason that you liked this
one so much and you don't usually like
these kind of arty slow burn type of
disjointed weird kind of movies is that
you know something bad is happening but
for a long time you don't know what it
is
so it's like you just see like these
really creepy like why does magna have
like a bite on her arm
why is you know why are they so like
intent on making him eat this
meat like what's in there like what
there's all these like little things
that are like conspiring
and you don't know for a really long
time what's going on and i will
and i can assure you that you will not
guess what is going on you don't find
out to the ends
and it's some pretty [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
it to me
the movie kind of reminded me of a more
modernized
updated version of the legacy where you
have some people together some of them
are kind of like religious figures and
some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] happens not a
series of murders
but it's a series of events that happen
and you can't
really it's not right but you can't
really put your finger on it
but it all starts to fall into place as
you find out more
it it's a cruddy ass [ __ ] house that
he's in and it's kind of creepy
uh i can't talk about it it'll [ __ ]
spoil it that's what i mean i really do
it all starts coming together in that
final
20 30 minutes of the damn move and
you're like oh that's what it was you
know it's just
and like i said pretty good and like i
said i can assure you that you
um you will not guess no we were trying
to figure it out it is
cuckoo for coco it's got a heart it's
kind of hard to fool us
[Laughter]
and i was like what the [ __ ] you know
what i mean there's some [ __ ] this is
right out of the left what the [ __ ] the
movie but it makes sense though
when you go back and like and this is
definitely one that i think
would benefit from a second viewing so
you could like catch all the stuff
that was happening because when you
don't really know what's going on you're
like what does that mean
why why is that like that like if you
liked midsummer
or uh [ __ ] wicker man and what was
the other one that was like that with
the damn
satanic kid the satanic kid i fell
asleep in it actually at the theater
i didn't like it i didn't like it oh
hereditary hereditary i love toronto
kind of like that
but better in fact i love hereditary so
much that i'm
kind of scared to watch it again because
it like bothered me so much i didn't
like her
[Laughter]
i i had a i guess i had inappropriate
responses to it
but evidently pretty common uh because i
heard people in the on on the
on the reviews saying that oh people
laughing at inappropriate times on the
heredity and i was like that must have
been me
yeah or there was a bunch of other
people that laughed at it
in what they called inappropriate well
like i said it depends on how you
and and we've talked about this before
and that woman said when that little
girl's head got smashed off
against by the car i laughed but that
was my
i just thought i didn't like the kids so
i just laughed you know
and i think you were supposed to like
the kid because she was terrible
yeah i didn't like kids but it was just
like
but a lot of people laughed evidently
well it was just it was a shocking
moment like the way and i really really
love
the way they did that sequence like
because it was just it wasn't a jump
scare it was just kind of like hey
check it out and then like the [ __ ]
crawling around on the ceiling to me i
just laughed at it
i just but other people were creeped out
by it i thought it was very creepy
that was just my reaction and it was one
of those ones too where if you go back
and watch it again
like there's cult members like
everywhere
in that movie and you don't see them
like they put put them in the background
there's like all this [ __ ] going on
i'd have to see it again i just got
turned off by the damn movie early on
i think i got we're talking about
heredity
hereditary hereditary yeah yeah i got
turned off by it i love you
i really did like that that was like
shut down and fell asleep in a couple
spots
i think that was one of the best i mean
i i don't think i know that was one of
the best horror movies that i saw in the
last
mid-summer which a lot of people didn't
like but i liked it i loved hereditary
or mid-summer also and [ __ ] the
wicker man
all are all kind of it's slightly in
this same shape yeah because this has a
pagani
it's got a pagan kind of claw veneer but
it's a horror movie it's not really
like i would say out of out of all of
them and be closer to hereditary
yeah and like i said if you saw that
turkish movie baskin
um if you saw under the shadow which was
uh a co-iranian british
uh production about a gin um that
thematically was kind of similar or you
know tonally was kind of similar
um so if you liked those you would
probably like this yeah
i feel like the i you know from what i
could see just of a quick
uh you know look over of the reviews and
stuff looks like about 75
positive reviews yeah um if you like
hereditary you'd like this but i got my
caveat is
is that i didn't like hereditary but i
liked this yeah but
the difference is is that i think the
storytelling in this is better
yeah than hereditary although i will say
that when it first started like i was
intrigued but it is a little
disjointed you gotta wait but you gotta
yeah you really this is one you really
kind of have to pay attention to because
it seems like every single thing like
means something you guys know me uh my
tastes are kind of childlike you know
what i mean i got that
i got that four or five minutes he likes
the tater tot movies right
i got that four or five minute rule
where if i'm not really pulled into it
within four or five minutes i'm never
gonna be pulled into that
movie well this one kept me interested
so and i was surprised i didn't think it
would but it did
there were a couple times i looked at my
[ __ ] tablet you know
because i knew what they were doing i
thought i did
you know what i mean but later on as it
got a little more
as things started to pick up you know i
was paying attention to it
yeah you know you know i was listening
to it
i didn't wasn't always watching it
wasn't real visual until later
yeah you know it's not don't expect any
kind of visual
stuff until you're like maybe 15 20
minutes into it and it almost at the end
like at the end it almost goes like
geology yeah it's real visual towards
the end
what the [ __ ] the situational
situational horror
yeah and like i said it goes crazy pants
and it doesn't [ __ ] spell it out
you gotta like you gotta this is the
movie
you need to interpret then there's all
these [ __ ] implications of what that
means
what they're doing it's just weird man
it's weird it was good though
thomas carlisle says the film long i
think it was about
an hour and 40. so not super simple no
it's not that long
and it didn't really i mean it didn't
seem that long to me but you know
i get your mileage may vary i think it
was an hour and 40 minutes dude's
getting all into this chick you know
but she's [ __ ] weird you know and
he's not really sure why and then he
finds out this situation
and man it's just weird it gets even
weirder yeah
you have to see i really did like i like
this movie because like
as soon as like the yeah as soon as the
uh credits came out i was like oh i like
that it was weird
yeah i liked the weird ass music they
had too thank you mango badger thank you
very much
flash ball for all the leopards and
follow them damn flash balls
flash bulbs at the airport
okay hey getting off the plane into
taking pictures of you yeah you like the
paparazzi you've arrived
bulbs at the airport just like out of
airplanes yeah yeah let's do some
flash bulbs you remember when you
actually had those cameras where you had
to snap the little flash
cube on there yeah and it turned yeah
when you [ __ ] advanced the film it
turned
well and all the young people are going
what the [ __ ] are you talking
for you had to change the cube out yeah
[ __ ] nasty
because well because you know it was
just like back in the [ __ ] old days
like in the 19th century when
photography was first invented
and you could only use the flash one
time because it was like pow and it
broke
and it was kind of like the same thing
only like in little cube form so you can
only use it once because it was like
popping that was like
i could tell people now those flash
cubes are what the [ __ ] unibomber
used as a [ __ ] igniter
to set the bomb off yep took that [ __ ]
apart and you get that
get those filaments out of there yeah
but that's thank you matt
thank you very much thomas carlos said
if tom isn't impressed within four
minutes wow tough crowd
he is a tough crowd well on his own
no i just noticed that if i'm not pulled
into the movie within four or five
minutes then the movie will never pull
me
then he won't get pulled into it and he
has to pretty much like be
right right from the get-go it has to be
right from the get-go if it's not then
it's a type of storytelling i don't like
yeah and i'll never get interested in
the movie and that's just the truth of
the matter
and that four or five-minute rule
has been consistently correct it used to
be a 10-minute rule
yeah but you're getting less patient as
you get older
[Laughter]
watching all those damn well we had that
we had that [ __ ]
amc a-list before amc went under
uh for a year it was a year and a half
maybe about a year
we overdosed on all those [ __ ] movies
and you real quickly after about four or
five months you start to
realize that most of these movies are
[ __ ]
well i think the problem too is that we
were trying to
make up the quota because we wanted
movies to review so there weren't always
like horror movies or sci-fi movies or
movies we wanted to see
you know so we ended up going to see a
bunch of [ __ ] that we didn't really care
about like [ __ ] dog movies and stupid
rom-coms and
[ __ ] like that it's like i don't want to
watch that most of them were [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then it's like and then after a
while we're like why are we even doing
that to ourselves
it was abusive yeah i challenge you to
go get
the amca list and use that [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] can't take it it might be better
in we were just using it to get out of
the house yeah and
sometimes if we really liked a movie
we'd go see it twice yeah
and we didn't have to pay again which
was nice but it's like
yeah i mean it's it's probably better
like in a big city where they actually
get more
indie movies or more movies i mean we're
in the middle of like central florida
and
we only get like the real big movies and
if you don't really want to see any of
those
then you're kind of hosed because you're
not going to get
any of the really weird ones some of the
ones that we saw that were good you know
like the john wick that was good
you know the marvel movies they're good
but then you forget them as soon as
they're over like what the [ __ ] happened
yeah in that movie and you know it's
just
and then but then a lot of them are just
like [ __ ] yeah
but some of them were very surprising
you know like art of self-defense i
[ __ ] loved it
which like i said that was another one
that i didn't think that you would like
yeah
i love that i want that [ __ ] on
blueberry if you guys want to give me a
birthday present and we've watched it
again like yeah
if you guys want to give me a birthday
present or something man you [ __ ]
send me
artist self defense on blu-ray i was one
of them i want um
rick shaw says if this movie's opening
credits don't pull me in i'm done
yeah yeah well what happened
it's gonna get to that point what ends
up happening is
that you you can watch so many new
movies as they come out
is that you just kind of [ __ ] detect
the [ __ ] early
i got like you know the one the hanzo at
the gretel and hansel one
yeah i knew that was going to be [ __ ]
but what was weird is that it was a
mixed bag of [ __ ]
it could have been great but it wasn't i
liked it but
it had elements of greatness but it
wasn't it wasn't great
there was it didn't give you enough of
what was great about the movie what was
great about the movie was the [ __ ]
witch it was the witch yeah
and then and when she was [ __ ] when
she'd get pretty and look all naked and
[ __ ] and all the weird special effects
and there should have been a lot of that
they should have turned that [ __ ] into
an
action movie okay well they already made
a hansel and gretel action movie should
have been an action movie
but i don't think that was but it should
have been at your action horror
yeah you know but the way the witch's
house looked and [ __ ]
it just it was it was good you know but
no no but then it kind of had a wrap
around and then there was
the hunter and the it's like get the
[ __ ] out of here this
what happened was is that the
traditional elements of hansel and
gretel
were forced into into the story and
those were the worst
parts of the story what was best was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that the director had
pulled out of his ass
yeah that's what the and that was a
better
it should have been it should not have
been hansel and gretel it should have
just been a story about that witch been
a witch story
which story yeah because there's not
enough witch stories no it should have
been a monster movie about it
and i especially dig like old school
witches yeah like the grody ones that
like turn into frogs and [ __ ]
well she was everything though yeah and
that was the chick that was in ghost
story when she was young
yeah alice creed i think all the [ __ ]
cannibalism in that most story was
[ __ ] weird you know and then
talking about turning her into which and
and eating the boy and
yeah and that boy did look delicious
yeah yeah it was [ __ ] awesome
but there just wasn't enough of it
oracle man says have you seen the vast
of night yet i haven't but it's on my
list i really want to see that next i've
heard that was like really really
excellent that's sci-fi that's a new
yeah
but and in our experience of the amc
hollywood doesn't deliver
uh it it's half ass most of the time in
general it doesn't deliver
it doesn't really give the audience what
they want to see
it uh it pull it's pulling too many
punches
uh it's a bunch of [ __ ]
with a very few exceptions like the
quentin tarantino movie gave the
audience exactly what they wanted to see
that was a [ __ ] good once upon a time
in hollywood
and i'm not a big tarantino fan once
upon a time in hollywood was a
was a really good one well that was
easily one of the best movies you saw
last year easily
yeah i mean i liked it a lot all right
so we've been going for half an hour
probably it seems like our power's going
to go out yeah
because it's uh storming really really
bad
and i'm getting like a little bit scared
all right so uh we're gonna
knock it off for the day and uh i think
our next live stream will be
for the regular episode saturday night
yeah
yeah okay so we'll uh see you guys
saturday like i said there'll still be
stuff witching hours going up tomorrow
movie reveal go friday and then we'll
see you guys on saturday for the main
show so we'll talk to you guys later bye